something truly stunning and disgusting
happened last night and I'm disgusted by
it
I don't I'm having trouble even putting
my thoughts together because it is so
vile and disgusting
last night I was planning to stream live
commentary on the CNN debate the first
night of it as I always do I started the
stream 15 minutes before the event at
the time that the debate itself started
our channel had 10,000 live viewers and
climbing very very quickly lots of
people wanted to watch my commentary on
the debate participate in the live shows
that we do around big political events
at 2 minutes past the hour 802 p.m.
Eastern CNN shut us down and they shut
us down hard
issuing what's called a hard copyright
strike to our YouTube channel in
addition to ending the stream on the
screen for you now is the takedown
notice you will notice at the bottom
left that it says manually detected this
means it was not an algorithm that
caught us inadvertently as someone
stealing their content but this was a
person whose name I've blurred out who
personally at CNN found our stream and
went out of their way to get us a
copyright strike you will notice in the
lower right of the screen it says strike
expires October 28 2019 this means we
are banned from all live streaming on
YouTube for 90 days this is a disaster
and this was optional ok there's a
mechanism for CNN to just take the ad
revenue from our stream but not shut it
down this is what NBC was doing the last
debate two channels of our size that are
not stealing content we have established
audiences this is fair use audiences
want to hear our commentary and we are
providing something of value we are not
just repeating a stream and adding
nothing CNN could have chosen to put a
third party claim on our video and allow
the stream to continue but they take the
ad revenue and I would have been fine
for that people support our streams with
super chats and memberships and the like
but instead they do this they choose to
jeopardize our account for three months
and then if you think this is just okay
not that crazy then it gets even more
disgusting the vice president and
spokesperson for CNN worldwide attacked
me on Twitter
implying that we are some kind of
fraudulent pirating operation take a
look at this insanity tweeting of course
you can't pirate content we spent
millions and millions to produce and the
irony of this is amazing first of all
you spent millions and millions to
produce one event that tells you the
scale and size of your operation why do
you care about an independent channel
like mine doing live coverage about your
event if this is the scale at which
you're operating which it is how does
what I'm doing even rank high enough to
number one trigger somebody to manually
seek me out and shut me down and number
two why are you even tweeting at me
you're the vice-president of a
department of CNN and of course using
the word pirating is so dismissive like
I get it I'm not CNN but this is a show
that's in YouTube's 1 or 2 top percent
were professionally produced we have an
audience of tens of thousands of people
who are waiting for my analysis pirating
impe lines implies I'm a guy in a
basement rebroadcasting a feed of the
debate alone not creating programming
with live callers and analysis and
something of value and then other CNN
flunkies jump right in liking this guy's
tweets a Hong kong-based CNN journalist
CNN's communications director just
loving loving how CNN is treating us and
this part is maybe the craziest okay I
don't know if it relates to this
copyright strike you might have noticed
that on YouTube we've had this join
button where you can become a YouTube
member for a few bucks a month we had
gotten up to almost a thousand of those
YouTube members this morning all
thousand of those are gone I don't know
if it's a glitch I've contacted YouTube
I've told them listen we got a copyright
strike I looked at our member list on
YouTube and it went from almost a
thousand to zero is this a glitch or
have we really lost the thousand members
on YouTube we spent a year building up
so this is bad sadly they basically won
my tools for fighting this are very
limited we've submitted a counterclaim
which takes ten business days to be
reviewed by YouTube and then after two
weeks of that they send it to CNN and
CNN has another month and they can
simply reject my counterclaim
contacted my YouTube rep I've contacted
the YouTube Twitter account so far no
dice so this is very very bad for us
live streams generate revenue for us we
were planning on doing maybe half a
dozen major ones in the next three
months around debates and other
political events one bit of success I
did go over to twitch last night I did
my first stream on Twitch and it went
pretty well so first and foremost follow
us on Twitter at twitch.tv/ludendi
don't let them win okay they take their
millions and millions like this guy told
me and they use it to shut down people
like me I hope that you will support us
directly I'm asking for you to do that
you can get a membership on our website
at join pakman.com takes under a minute
really supports the work that we're
doing helps us fight this type of stuff
or you can throw us a pledge of as
little as $1 a month on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show it's
bad out there it's bad make sure you're
following me on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman hope to see you there
tonight